hello my name is Papa moon mark and I
come from Bangkok Thailand today I'm in
a city called hala a coastal city with
rich tradition in history so when I come
join me in my discovery of hala
my first stop is here in the market
church looks really tall from here so I
think I'm going to go up and see a great
view of the city oh my god
until the out of breath wow what a nice
view of hathor it's a mixture of
medieval and modern feelings together I
must take a picture so if you look down
from a tower in Bangkok you see a lot of
traffic and cars but here's so spacious
and you can see a lot of people walking
it's amazing I like it here
hello the city of spires actually
counted five already I just feel like
I'm in southern Italy it's so wonderful
I'm enjoying this so I've heard that
they found something really important
inside of the city of Hydra I think it's
some kind of a star map so let's check
it out together
I'm standing here looking at this and I
feel really touched and I'm proud to be
part of the human civilization so at the
back of me here is called the Celina you
know I've heard that challah has a long
history of salt making and I'm a little
bit curious so come join me and see
what's inside
welcome to the Celina
please step inside
it's really heavy you know who would
have thought that just boiling salt
requires such strength and labor isn't
it nice to sitting here next to the
river salad isn't the view gorgeous I
think this is the best way to end my
perfect journey in the city of Halle
today so I hope you enjoyed it as much
as I did auf wiedersehen